I've spent my life
trying to protect my family
but I always lead them
into more danger.
I have cursed
everyone that I love
with war.
♪♪
Season 3
there are new threats
Baba Voss is just trying
to keep his family together
Baba is trying to stop these
powerful forces
threatening the world
in the name of science.
This new weapon,
more powerful than you can
imagine.
Tormada is this mad-scientist
who discovers how to make bombs
and he's like a general to Edo.
Tormada is twisted and
all about what tools
can he use to
destroy his enemies.
The enemy of my enemy
is my friend.
We will build
the greatest empire
this world has ever known.
All of Paya will be ours.
Bomb them.
♪♪
Theres a power struggle
between Sibeth and Maghra.
Both women fight for
what they believe in.
Your hands should stay clean.
It's too late for that.
Violence must be met
with violence.
♪♪
There comes a point
where family
needs to put a line down
and make really
difficult decisions.
♪♪
Her army is in Paya
with weapons of
thunder and fire.
It's a very different
kind of threat
for Baba Voss.
♪♪
You need to ready your
army to march.
You will have us go to war?
You're already at war!
Fire!
♪♪
This season, the actions
just jacked up.
And there's real sacrifices.
♪♪
Kill them!
Run!
I will die...
-No!
before I allow anything
to happen to you.
♪♪